[ ALARM ]
>>> HEY FELLAS.
>> OH!
>> WE DID IT, CAPTAIN SHADOW.
>> BUT THE KILLER CLOWN HAS
STILL ELUDED US ONCE AGAIN.
LET'S HURRY BACK TO HIS SHADOW
CAVE AND INSPECT THIS SERIOUS
CLUE THAT HE LEFT BEHIND.
>> THAT SICK BASTARD WILL NEVER
GET AWAY WITH WHATEVER HE IS
PLANNING, THANKS TO US.
>> DON'T GET TOO COCKY,
CARDINAL.
KILLER CLOWN WILL STILL --
[ SIRENS ]
-- OH, GODDAMN IT.
IT'S THE COPS.
>> TURN OFF THE ENGINE.
>> THEY PROBABLY JUST WANT TO
THANK US.
>> YEAH, I BET.
LOOK, JUST BE COOL.
LET ME DO ALL THE TALKING, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
I WON'T SAY A WORD.
>> GOOD MORNING, FELLAS.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> HELLO, OFFICER.
>> NICE MASKS.
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS, COMING FROM A
PARTY OR SOMETHING?
>> NO, SIR.
>> BUT I GUESS YOU COULD SAY WE
BUSTED ONE UP, RIGHT CAPTAIN
SHADOW?
>> SHUT UP CARDINAL.
>> OKAY.
>> ANY IDEA HOW FAST YOU WERE
GOING?
>> UH, I MEAN -- I'M REALLY NOT
SURE.
65, 70 MAYBE?
>> I CLOCKED YOU GUYS AT 140.
>> OH.
>> YEAH.
LICENSE AND REGISTRATION,
PLEASE, SIR.
>> IT'S ME.
IT'S CAPTAIN SHADOW.
THIS IS MY TRUSTY SIDEKICK
CARDINAL.
>> THE DYNAMITE TWOSOME AT YOUR
SERVICE.
>> HEY CARDINAL, WILL YOU JUST
SHUT UP?
>> OKAY, SO YOU'RE RAPPERS OR
SOMETHING.
I STILL NEED TO SEE I.D.
>> NO, WE'RE NOT RAPPERS.
AND MY IDENTITY IS A SECRET, SO.
>> A SECRET.
>> YEAH, I'M A CRIME FIGHTER.
>> YOU REALLY DON'T RECOGNIZE
US?
>> HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> 16.
>> OH, GOD.
>> IS THAT YOUR SON?
>> NO, BUT WE LIVE TOGETHER IN A
CAVE.
>> OKAY, OUT OF THE CAR.
LET'S GO.
>> CARDINAL, THAT'S GOING TO BE
YOUR BIGGEST SETBACK.
YOU DON'T LISTEN.
>> WHAT, YOU NEED HELP?
GET OUT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> BEEN DRINKING TODAY?
>> NO, SIR.
>> CAPTAIN SHADOW WOULD NEVER
DRINK.
>> HEY.
>> UH-HUH.
YEAH, PRETTY SWEET RIDE YOU'VE
GOT.
YOU'VE GOT A FIRE COMING OUT OF
THE EXHAUST.
I DON'T SEE A LICENSE PLATE ON
THIS THING.
>> YEAH, WELL, OF COURSE NOT.
IT'S THE SHADOW MOBILE, ALL
RIGHT?
I MADE THIS CAR MYSELF.
>> YEAH, BECAUSE HE'S A GENIUS.
>> HEY, WAS I TALKING TO YOU?
>> NO, BUT HE IS.
>> OKAY.
HANDS ON THE HOOD.
>> OKAY, I REALLY DON'T THINK --
>> LET'S GO, COME ON.
ALRIGHTY.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING THAT WILL
STICK ME?
>> PROBABLY.
>> ANY WEAPONS OR GUNS?
>> CAPTAIN SHADOW WOULD NEVER
USE GUNS, BECAUSE GUNS ARE FOR
COWARDS.
RIGHT CAPTAIN SHADOW?
>> WOULD YOU SHUT UP, CARDINAL!
>> SURE.
>> WHAT IS THIS?
>> IT'S MY UTILITY BELT.
>> YEAH, WHAT'S ON IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW -- SMOKE BOMBS.
STRAPS, GADGETS, THERE'S A
LOT --
>> UH-HUH.
>> THIS REALLY ISN'T NECESSARY.
JUST CALL COMMISSIONER MORGAN,
HE KNOWS WHO I AM.
>> YEAH.
1085, I'M GOING TO NEED A CAR.
>> DAM IT, DAM IT, DAM IT.
ANY TIME A
BLACK MAN WANTS TO DO SOMETHING
GOOD FOR HIS COMMUNITY, WE'VE
GOT TO GO THROUGH SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
EVERY TIME.
>> WHAT'S THIS?
>> WHAT'S WHAT?
>> THE BAG.
WHAT'S IN IT?
>> THAT'S -- THAT'S DUST.
IT'S ENERGY DUST.
>> OH, YEAH?
LOOKS A LITTLE BIT LIKE COCAINE.
>> OH, PLEASE.
>> YEAH, WELL -- IT'S NOT
COCAINE.
IT'S LIKE COCAINE, BUT IT'S
DIFFERENT.
>> HE JUST NEEDS IT, FOR ENERGY
AND FOR COURAGE.
>> SHUT YOUR TRAP.
>> ALL RIGHT, WHAT SEEMS TO BE
THE PROBLEM HERE?
HEY CAPTAIN SHADOW, WHAT'S GOING
ON MY BROTHER?
WHAT'S THIS RIGHT HERE?
OH, THAT'S COCAINE.
>> WELL, IT'S NOT MINE.
IT'S NOT MINE.
>> HE JUST SAID IT WAS YOUR
ENERGY DUST.
>> DID I SAY THAT?
BUT IT'S NOT MINE.
I PROBABLY CONFISCATED IT.
AND JUST FORGOT ABOUT IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO AHEAD AND
GET YOU SOME CUFFS.
>> WAIT -- WE DON'T NEED THOSE.
>> OH, NO.
CAPTAIN SHADOW, WHAT SHOULD I
DO?
>> CALL MY OLD LADY, TELL HER
THEY GOT ME AGAIN, CARDINAL.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]